Và bình đề bức súc nhất mà nhiều vụ huyên thẳng ngánh đó là có những trường thị sếp trường trình học đến cách xem kẹ với dừa học chính quán.
Và khi đó thì bất đất dưới vụ huyên thầy cho con thông ra.
Bởi vì nếu không đang ký cho con thông ra thì con sẽ thể thách ra để xin hoạt giân.
Và khi đó thì cách chấu sẽ khọt thấy rất là miệt với bạn này và sẽ nãy xích tâm lý mặt càng.
Và phân biểu chỉ đạo bất nền này chỉ đồng chỉ tổng vý thư trụ trình nước gạyêu cầu.
Và không thể biến trường học tháng nơi làm gì cụ tuy tiền.
Và yêu cầu là ngày ra xuất để kiểm tra ngày hí biệt là nhà nước thì miễn học bị cho các chấu.
Nhưng mà nhà chường kìa đại tổ chức ra nhiều việc khác để thu tiền nhiều hơn trong đó có viện đề học linh kết.
Và đối với bình đề này chỉ chúng tôi xin kiến nghị là trước hết là yêu cầu là phải nghiêm,
và biệt sẽ chung trình học linh kết xem kẹ với dừa học chính quán.
Và để nghĩ bộ giấu dục tháng chắc kìm trang giân.
Và kể đó thì nếu chúng ta vẫn tiếp tục dưới chí biệt học linh kết này thì cũng cần thể bảo đam tính chất của trường thông.
Đó là cái sự không 2,5 bạc biệt tại chính và sự chia sẻ chỉ vì với các phủ quyền.
Tránh kết việc là dành nghĩa phạt lực, giành nghĩa thì là có nhiều mà phạt lực thì lại như là tương.
Và phủ quyền kể lại phải bỏng một kể phạt chỉ vì rất là lớn.
Và về lâu dài thì chúng tôi xin kiến nghị bệ bộ giáo dục cần nghiên kìu để có kế hoa.
Nào tạo tình dục mồi giữa các phủ giáo viên ở trong phùng trong nghiệp phương.
Để có thể đáp ở biệt dệ, các biệt môn học này.
Tránh nghiệp là học lùi bố đất đủ kiến thức kể lại khai nguyên kết học.